I would say relax don't worry about the
debt don't worry about the debt until
the virus is gone and actually don't
worry about the debt after the virus is
gone but the priority right now is still
you have an economy that is severely a
lot of people are not able to do what
they normally do for a living because of
the of the pandemic and your goal is to
make that tolerable to make it possible
for people to continue to afford what
they need and both for their own sake
and because that contains the spillovers
means that the parts of the economy that
are operating are not suffering from a
collapse and demand from the parts that
are not and just keep that keep keep
this keep things afloat maintain the the
support maintain the emergency relief
while you deal with the virus and after
that let's talk but I suspect that
economic recovery is going to be a lot
easier than a lot of people imagine I'm
reluctant optimist I mean I'm my my
personality probably tends towards
pessimism and I was very much a
pessimist about the pace of recovery
from the last crisis but this one is
different this is something this is just
kind of an external headwind it's not
that the economy had something
fundamentally wrong with it it's just
that this thing hit us and and stopped
us dead because of it was such a severe
shock but as soon as that is removed you
expect the economy to come roaring back